série votre vernis spectacle s'appelle
camping cars for ever c'est jamais
facile de trouver un autre spectacle
c'est vrai tu t'appelles comment ton
spectacle laurent baffie se pose des
questions
ah ça s'appelle comment ase merci alors
si vous venez de vous donner des noms
attendait c'était quoi bah vous allez
voir je vous donnais des onze spectacles
a vous de me dire s'ils ont vraiment
existé où chacun est ce qu'on a vu
norbert tarayre jouer son spectacle one
man chaud patate
oui oui oui c'est vrai one man chaud
patate ça existe et est ce qu'on a vu
texte joué son spectacle tex in the city
oui oui oui s'ébruite c'est bon est ce
qu'on a vu michel cymes jouer dans son
spectacle un indien dans la ville
non non je pense que si tu lui envoyer
cette affiche
vous seriez moins fâché parce que les
jolies cet appel à nous envoyer alors vu
les ventes jouer leur spectacle auto
temps d'emporter ses risques derrière
l'auteur je sus côte c'est vrai
absolument série s on a vu eric zemmour
jouer son spectacle 1 2 3 la france
c'est fini
non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la france a activé sa dent lui les gens
se désabonnent est ce qu'on a vu anne
roumanoff jouer son spectacle anne
roumanoff
oui oui c'est vrai mais est ce qu'on a
vu mac lesggy jouer dans son spectacle e
égal m circoncis petite foule à un bout
de jambon c'est quand même un monde
les chevaliers du fiel alors bon arbre
aux barbares d'autres spectacles où ces
campings cars for ever tranquille qui
c'est qui choisit les affiches comme ça
c'est vous et moi on a une idée puis on
a il y en a un super super photographe
qui d'ailleurs dessous nous sommes et
qui travaille à paris qui est le plus
grand photographe d'affiche je pense
s'appelle pascalito qu'on salue et crée
toujours des super belles photos mariage
et j'ai vu vous êtes avec un couple
d'allemands gardez vous exactement car
je sais j'ai donc j'ai vu le j'ai vu le
spectacle et je vois je réussis fut et
vous êtes très sexy dedans foods et sans
aucun produit sans rien le site
allemande
oui ça m'a beaucoup plu
sachez le